We're going to look at five key concepts in evolutionary thinking.
The first of which is natural selection.
Natural selection presents us with a puzzle because it creates the appearance of
a design without having a design in mind or even having a mind at all.
There is no agent that's actively selecting anything.
How does it do that?
Natural selection occurs whenever these four necessary conditions are fulfilled.
First,
there's variation in reproductive success.
Second,
there's variation in the treat of interest.
Third,
there's a non zero correlation between reproductive success and the trait and
forth.
The state of the treat is heritable.
There's genetic variation for the tree.
When in doubt returned to these basic conditions.
They help you to understand whether or not natural selection could be operating
on anything.
Let's unpack them.
First,
variation in reproductive success.
Now to a first approximation in humans.
This is variation and completed family size and that means lifetime reproductive
success,
abbreviated LRS or children ever born,
abbreviated CEB in bacteria and cancer cells.
It's variation in time and survival between cell divisions.
Now to reproduce one must survive of course.
Thus reproductive success is a composite of survival and reproduction.
The probability of surviving to reproduce times the number of offspring produced
some over the reproductive period.
Now you'll note that selection acts directly via reproductive success and only
indirectly via survival to the extent that survival is contributing to
reproductive success.
This is an important point and it's because of this distinction that we can see
how aging evolves.
Now variation in reproductive success is universal.
We have two examples here.
On the top panel we have the monogamous Pitcairn islanders and in the bottom
panel the polygynous doggone.
In Mali,
males are in blue,
females are in red.
On the x axis we have the number of offspring that are particular individual
had.
On the y axis we have the number of people who had that number of offspring and
you can see that in both populations there's great variation in reproductive
success.
Any trait that correlates with reproductive success in these populations will
experience selection and whether then response to selection is is going to
depend on whether it is heritable on whether it's underpinned by genetic
variation.
Yeah.
Variation in the trait is then the another key factor.
The trait could be anything.
It could be eye color,
height,
the temperature dependence,
and then have an enzymatic reaction.
The structure of the ribosomes assess susceptibility to a disease.
Those are all possible traits that could be under selection.
If the trait does not vary,
there can be no competition for improved reproductive performance among treat
variants.
Okay.
Natural selection does not operate on things that do not vary.
Now,
most traits do vary among individuals and most traits therefore can potentially
come under selection.
Here's an example,
variation and resistance to malaria.
Here you have a table of sickle cell genotypes across sub Sahara.
In Africa there are 10 rows each for a different region of Africa.
These two columns show the infected and uninfected people that have the s Oleo,
the sickle Leo,
and these two columns show the infected and uninfected people who are Aa
homozygotes.
So s codes for sickle cell and a is for the normal hemoglobin.
You can see down here at the bottom the percentage of people infected and if you
examine those,
you'll see that the sickle cell carriers were about 6% less likely to be
infected by malaria than the normal homozygotes.
Now the s s homozygotes suffer from anemia,
the Aa homozygotes suffer from malaria and the essay heterozygotes are protected
from malaria.
So this is an example where genetic variation is being maintained in these
populations by the selection pressure exerted by disease.
In this case we have a lot of information on the biochemical basis.
The s variant is caused by a mutation in the sixth position of the Beta globin
chain of hemoglobin and that results in the replacement of hydrophilic glutamic
acid by hydrophobic veiling.
So here is a case in which we can go right from the molecular level up to the
population level to understand why genetic variation is being maintained in the
population.
And we can also see that disease is playing an important role in selection on
humans.
Okay.
The next criterion,
the next condition is that the correlation between reproductive success and the
trait of interest must be non zero.
Even if there's variation in reproductive success and variation in the trait,
that doesn't mean that natural selection is operating.
Those are necessary conditions,
but they are not yet sufficient.
There must also be a correlation between the value of the trait and reproductive
success.
For example,
patients who resist disease may reproduce more often than patients who don't.
Yeah.
What in general generates such correlations?
Well,
they are produced by myriad circumstances in the biology of humans and also in
their culture.
An important element of human culture is now medicine.
Medicine is actually generating correlations between reproductive success and
traits of interest.
There was thus no single general cause of selection.
Selection occurs for a huge variety of reasons that include anything that causes
variation in reproductive success.
Yeah.
Let's take a look at one example.
Here is a table of uh,
traits with are correlated that are correlated with reproductive success and
they come from women in Framingham,
Massachusetts,
born between 1890 and 1960.
The traits are cholesterol,
height,
weight,
age at first birth and agent menopause.
This Beta is not strictly speaking a correlation coefficient.
It is a selection gradient and it has the same sign is a correlation
coefficient.
You can see that the sample sizes are large,
the p values are small.
These are all significant effects.
What we can see from this table is that in this period for women in Framingham,
selection was acting to decrease their total cholesterol to decrease their
height,
the increase their weight to decrease their age at first birth and to increase
their agent menopause.
So selection is acting in a contemporary human population and this result is
fairly general.
It's been confirmed in other populations as well.
The next necessary condition is that the state of the trait must be heritable.
That is the critical genetic condition that allows what worked in the past to be
remembered and improvements to accumulate.
It does interacts with natural selection to generate order out of disorder.
However,
inheritance must not be 100% perfect.
If it were genetic variation could not originate in the first place,
and if for some reason it already existed,
then natural selection would rapidly eliminated.
By selecting the best variants,
there has to be some mutation to create the mute.
The variation.
That's the fuel on which the motor selection runs,
but not so much mutation that destroys too much of the useful information on
what worked in the past.
So there must be some intermediate,
fairly low optimal rate.
Okay.
Here are the heritabilities of some human traits.
Yeah,
age at first birth.
Oh 0.11 blood traits like cholesterol,
somewhere around old 0.4 or 0.3 or 0.4 agent menopause about old 0.6 height
about oh 0.75 and all of these traits are capable of responding to selection,
but height will respond more rapidly than age at first birth,
because it's heritability is higher for an equivalent selection pressure.
That means that height will respond more rapidly than Asia first birth.
Okay?
Now,
heritabilities are things that can vary from zero to one.
Zero means no more resemblance between relatives.
Then between people chosen at random,
and one means that offspring have exactly the same value is the average of their
parents.
So human traits have significant genetic variation and can respond to selection.
Okay,
let's take a look at natural selection in action.
The rapid evolution of antibiotic resistance in Staphylococcus is illustrated by
what is pretty much a standard history of introducing new drugs to combat
bacterial infection.
In 1943 penicillin became commercially available and staphylococcus was
resistant.
By 1947 there was a switch to methicillin.
In the 60s methicillin resistance was rising.
By the eighties by the 1990s 35% of isolates were resistant to methicillin.
There was then a switch to Vancomyocin.
By 1996 Vancomyocin resistance was reported and Linezolid was approved in 2000
by the FDA and by 2000 to linezolid resistance was reported in staphylococcus.
This is a fairly representative standard history of the way that bacteria
respond to the introduction of antibiotics.
They repeatedly Reeve evolve resistance.
Okay?
It's caused by strong selection that elicits a rapid response.
Bacterial populations are huge.
There are large numbers of genetic variants that are continually generated by
mutation,
but also importantly introduced by horizontal gene transfer and generation times
are very short.
Antibiotic therapy creates huge differences in the reproductive success of
different variants in the bacterial population.
The trait that varies is resistance.
That variation has a genetic basis.
Antibiotics select resistant clones,
which then have greater reproductive success.
Okay.
There are other examples of natural selection,
clinical medicine,
and in public health,
the evolution of metastatic cancer involves natural selection.
The evolution of resistance to cancer chemotherapy involves natural selection.
The coevolution of pathogens with host defenses.
Yeah,
leading to the evasion and to manipulation
involves natural selection.
The evolution of pathogen variants in response to changes in transmission and to
vaccination campaigns involves natural selection and the impacts of medical
practice on human pathogen and cancer.
Evolution all involve natural selection.
So to summarize,
selection occurs whenever variation in a trade is correlated with reproductive
success traits.
Experience selection only respond if their variation is heritable.
Selection produces a significant response when the events that generated occur
frequently and consistently.
Selection efficiently creates order out of disorder,
producing the appearance of design that we call adaptation.
Okay.
No agent is actively selecting the process emerges unsupervised from any
circumstances that correlate heritable variation in traits with reproductive
success.
Natural selection is largely a numbers game.
It occurs in response to things that happen frequently and consistently.